joining us with more reaction senator
lindsey graham senator i happen to be
privy to a conversation that you had
with president trump and
you were very passionately
talking to the president at the time
about the need to keep minimal forces
and how this
how to properly withdraw
and
keep
prevent things like this from happening
and keep the gains that were made in
place you successfully came to an
agreement
this is not what donald trump handed joe
biden's blaming donald trump this is not
the plan you and donald trump agreed to
now this is all on president biden he's
done two very
he took the most dangerous and
dishonorable path available he ignored
sound military advice
there is no plan to get u.s citizens
outside of kabul into kabul and once
they get to kabul there's no plan to
make the taliban to let them through but
here's what i take today from the news
conference that we just issued a death
sentence to all those who fought with us
in afghanistan it is clear to me they're
resetting the table here and they're
trying to move the ball and say we're
going to focus on american citizens and
we're going to leave behind the
thousands of afghans who honorably
fought along our side that's what
they're saying today so two things have
happened here one the chance of another
9 11 is tenfold because of the way
binance handled this and the chance of
other people helping us in the future
after this debacle is almost zero so joe
biden and apparently our generals and
our secretary of defense are willing to
sacrifice
all those who helped us because they
don't have the will or the determination
to get them out
senator i want to ask you this because
we have untold thousands of americans
now behind enemy lines and yes those
that assisted america those interpreters
those people that we promised god forbid
it ever comes to this we will protect
you they're not being protected
but i don't see any military option
because every american then right would
become a human shield
and
i don't even want to describe what we
both know would happen
there's no military option senator you
know we're we're at the mercy of the
taliban now
well well well change it you don't have
to be at the mercy of the taliban my god
you don't think we can beat these guys
if we want to here's what i would do if
i were president united states i would
tell the pentagon to give me a safe
quarter passage plan for every corner of
afghanistan i would tell the taliban
we're bringing every american home
they're coming from every corner of
afghanistan if you get in the way that
will be a hostile act against the united
states and we will use military force i
will tell them the same about the
interpreters and all those that helped
us we don't have to accept this
all right senator lindsey graham we
appreciate you being with us
we're praying for our fellow americans
when we come back the great one mark
levin has some very strong words for joe
biden his disastrous plan americans now
behind enemy lines how do we get them
out how do we bring them home straight
ahead
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else